Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
Thank you, Ruffians!
We made it to the end of the week!
And today, it's the 79th episode!
Thank you for joining us!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
We did it!
It's just about the weekend.
Wow.
Ruffians!
I saw that today is Joshua's first time joining us live for FUWAMOCO Morning, so we couldn't explain.
Well, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short-format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
That is hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face
I hope you start your day off on the right paw!
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag "hashtag FUWAMOCO Morning"!
Have you ever seen morning?
Moco-chan, do your job okay?
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
You think in the 79th time you'd be good at something, huh?
It doesn't quite always go that way, huh?
Yeah, hi to the new FUWAMOCO Morning viewers!
And hi to our regular FUWAMOCO Morning viewers, too!
Hi!
BAU BAU!
I have a feeling it's gonna be a very good day today, huh?
Yeah.
But... Ruffians... Does this make your day any better?
Because I...
There was another hero sighting.
Does this make your day better?
Why?
Or worse?
Where was he spotted, Moco-chan?
Wow.
If the Ruffians say it's better, okay.
Prepare yourself.
De-den.
Did Pero make his visual novel debut?
For us?
It's not like I'm envious, but... Well... It looks like, you know, this VN dates back quite a while.
Looking at the UI and everything.
Violence.
That sounds good.
Yeah?
But, but, but, but... Actually, Ruffians!
The thing that I like the best is that... Do you see on the side there, right beside me?
See, you have all your tools and options to use on Pero... I guess the... You don't mean... I guess that'd be Pero.
See, at the top we have our magic claws.
I guess you know if you're gonna use that and... Maybe...
What would happen if you use the gnome on Pero?
You never know, and that's what makes it so much fun!
You know, modern visual novels, they just don't really have this feature anymore.
It's too bad.
I like it.
You know, it's exciting.
You never know what's gonna happen in the hidden dialogues.
But now I want to go and play more visual novels.
Well, Ruffians!
Have fun on the Peron road!
Good luck!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, they don't make them quite like that, huh?
Maybe that's a good thing, huh?
No pedals.
Oh, that just means we have to go back to Super Horse 5.
Right.
Wow, Ruffians!
You know how FUWAMOCO we like to sing.
We do.
Well, actually, our most recent song cover of Speed's White Love has hit over 400k listens on YouTube!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you so much for listening to it and loving it a bunch!
Right.
You know, we were really nervous to release it, you know, since it might not be the most well-known song outside of Japan.
But we're so happy that you like our cover!
And that we were able to share a song that's really special to us together with you.
You know, FUWAMOCO, we like to cover a bunch of different types of songs from many different decades.
And, well, we'll continue to do that even though there might be some less known songs included in there too.
We hope that you'll continue to look forward to more music from us, okay?
You're happy to be introduced to it!
Thank you, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
So happy.
I wonder when our next song cover will be.
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO, the day has already started off on the right paw because just a few hours earlier, we had our first collab with Asuka-chan by playing Geoguessr all together on her channel!
I know, AZKi-senpai!
She's a super pro at GeoGuessr.
And you know, she even made some custom maps for us to try and guess where we were!
It was our first time, but we had so much fun all together!
You know, we visited Shinjuku Gyoen, a famous park in Shinjuku, and stopped by Coin Laundry Fuwawa Hut!
My coin laundry!
Not a perfect shirt!
And of course, it was perfect.
We ended up
Our Holy Land Mystery Donut in Akihabara!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, it was really really fun, but one thing, one thing that we learned though, even though you know FUWAMOCO, we're not the best with maps, and not the best with directions, but
As long as we can find a Mister Donut location, we can find our way around!
Somehow, huh?
I don't think we've been to that many Mister Donut locations.
I don't know, I think we have.
But then, when I think about it... Yeah.
Yeah.
It really was so much fun!
We hope to play more with AZKi-senpai in the future too!
Yeah, that would be nice.
Would you like that, Ruffians?
More geoguessr?
It was really fun!
I thought it was gonna be very scary.
Right!
Ruffians, we got a perfect score!
Thanks to AZKi-senpai!
We were just having too much fun.
Who cares about the score, huh?
It was fun!
Thank you AZKi-senpai!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
The perfect way to start the day right.
BAU BAU!
Wow, Ruffians!
We actually got a scoop!
From you!
Thank you!
Thank you so much to Mr. BAU BAU for the impeccable journal!
BAU BAU!
Well, let's see what we have for the scoop.
We have... De-den!
It looks like Kaori-senpai has just...
A big milestone!
1,000 videos on her channel!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Congratulations!
That's a huge accomplishment.
1,000 videos!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
So many hours, so much love, right?
Right, and all the memories, too.
Yeah, a thousand memories.
20 of those, just 20?
Just 20?
I wonder.
Many, many hours, though, definitely.
Yeah, but FUWAMOCO, you know, we're just newbies, too, but...
Seeing this kind of big accomplishment makes us really want to work hard too so that one day maybe we can hit that milestone too.
Let's try not to rush.
BAU BAU!
Congratulations!
Well...
Ruffians!
Did you see on Twitter the other day?
We sort of shared a post about a Mococo Christ kid figure!
That was still a work in progress, right?
It was amazing, right?
Yeah, well, Ruffians actually the creators shared support of data photos!
It's not just Moco-chan, but also me as well!
I guess Pero's dead too, huh?
What an amazing prototype pie!
Look at it!
Well, Ruffians, maybe you're like, I need more!
These photos!
Ruffians, if you're interested in the area, you can actually see them on display in person at this weekend's Wonder Festival event happening in Japan.
In case, you know, there are some Ruffians wondering just what Garage Kitchen, what Wonder Festival is.
A garage kit or a resin kit is often a fan-made model that you assemble yourself.
It's often made of resin.
Makes sense, huh?
You know?
So that means that usually it just comes unpainted, unassembled parts.
And you put that all together yourself.
Okay.
It's tricky.
You need to put all the pins and glues and paints and equipment.
Safety precautions.
Not something that FUWAMOCO can do.
No.
Although that'd be fun.
But, you know, at Wonder Festival, at this event, you can find many types of these kind of figure kits, but also, much much more.
Much more!
You know, you can find whatever the imagination dreams of.
Whether it's monsters, or animals, or anime figures.
Lots of things!
Much, much, much more!
You know, it's almost like an art museum where you can take a picture.
Lots of stuff to look at!
Well, FUWAMOCO, you know we talked about it before, but we really love figures.
We do!
And we've seen the amazing creativity from everyone, too.
So even if you can't go to the venue, if you're interested, you can check out the hashtag #WF2024W on Twitter to see more from Wonder Festival.
There's so much, okay?
Yeah.
Thank you so much for the amazing FUWAMOCO prototype kit!
BAU BAU!
Really, really impressive.
Yeah.
We really wanna get our paws on it one day.
Just look.
Just look for now, okay?
Just for now, okay.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
So cool!
Right?
Amazing.
BAU BAU!
It's been a while, huh?
It's been a little while, but... There's been a misunderstanding.
Yeah.
FUWAMOCO!
It's not... I didn't do this, Moco-chan.
I didn't do anything either.
It's just a misunderstanding, okay?
It's a misunderstanding.
Yeah.
Ruffians!
We noticed that there are some of you who think that
FUWAMOCO, we might be planning out and scripting our streams, but especially our game streams in particular!
First, you know, with the plan sinking, and now scripting of our game streams.
Well, um, unfortunately, we do not script our game streams.
That would be an interesting idea though, huh?
Right.
Yeah.
It's all planned!
Right!
We'd have to be genius puppies, but no, we don't plan what happens.
We don't plan how many times we die.
We die many, many times.
You know that.
And we don't know what kind of silly things we're gonna get ourselves into.
You know, well, in fact, you know, we generally know next to nothing about the majority of the games we're playing since, you know, most of them are playing for the first time.
We don't know spoilers.
Spoilers are fun.
Even, you know, we played Bread and Bread.
I don't really know what it's gonna be.
I know.
This is gonna be fun.
It's gonna be fun, I just know that.
Yeah.
Is that a spoiler?
I don't think so.
Yeah.
But you know what?
Usually we'll see if we have some sort of knowledge of the game, you know, like Touhou or if we've played it before.
Right.
Yeah, so, uh... Ruffians, if you can imagine, I think it'd be really hard to plan things out, you know?
Right?
Even if you have played the game before, you know, trying to get certain events to happen, I think it'd be really, really tricky, right?
Just maybe hard!
If anything, I'd like to see a VTuber who can try to do that hard.
Right!
It'd be really rough, but...
Crazy dedication, huh?
Can you imagine?
Trying to plan out an 8 hour stream of Power World with Metal Gear Solid, huh?
Impressiveness only, right?
Genius planners.
I don't know what's gonna happen.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
But yes, unfortunately FUWAMOCO, we're just seriously silly.
Sometimes it might be hard to believe, but these are just the hazards we get ourselves into naturally.
We're just silly.
Got it.
Understood.
Seriously silly.
Sorry!
We're just shooting!
Just shooting!
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan!
It's time for the Doggie of the Day!
Let's see who the Doggie of the Day of today is.
We have De-den!
It's Moco!
I feel like Rogue is such a fitting name, right?
I love the eyebrows!
Big ears, big tongue!
Yeah, and we have the little polka dot!
Polka dot on the side there.
She looks like such a big, cuddly puppy!
Right!
Yeah, strong doggo, strong Rogue!
Tag twice!
Yeah, apparently, you know, she's not really allowed on the couch it seems, but...
Well, it sure looks like she's pretending that she's not that familiar with the rules, huh?
There's a rule I'm not supposed to go on the couch.
No sofa for me.
Well, nobody's here.
I'm sure.
Well, I'll just kind of snuggle up to you.
There's a spot.
All right.
It looks like it says BAU BAU.
Hi!
Well, how does BAU BAU look?
BAU BAU!
I think so.
You know, Moco was once a little puppy.
And now, now she's a big puppy!
She's grown up lots and I'm sure her love for you has too.
Please give her lots of head pats.
Let her follow you around wherever life takes you, okay?
I can tell she wants to be by your side no matter what.
The puppy heart doesn't go away, okay?
That even means if that takes her to getting in trouble for being on the sofa too.
She'll get in trouble if it means she gets to be close to you.
BAU BAU!
Cute!
And for today I went on a walk, we have... De-den!
Some pretty flowers!
Interesting clouds too!
It's a bit hard to see, but... Yeah, it looks maybe like it's a bit stormy, but...
Really cool.
It kind of matches with the fluffiness of the flowers, the fluffiness of the clouds.
You have some purple flowers, and some greenish flowers, and some grayish flowers.
You know, it looks like you also have the perfect friend joining you on that walk too!
Thank you for accompanying this Ruffian booboo!
BAU BAU!
And for today's Question of the Day, we have... De-den!
Cute!
FUWAMOCO!
Question!
If you could travel in time to 3000 BC, what item would you bring with you and how would you use it?
Me?
I'd bring my phone to take selfies.
Oh, that's a tricky question, but... I like the cellphone idea.
It's a pretty good idea, I think.
Right?
You know, taking lots of photos and selfies, that would be fun.
Just like this here!
So cute.
I don't think the photo spot's so high.
You have to make your own.
Yeah.
Moco-chan, what would you bring?
Maybe a big jug of water.
Is this one?
I can carry one in each arm.
I feel like I would get thirsty.
What if you're getting chased by like a wild animal or something?
I'll just throw it at them.
Two ways of cheating!
I guess it did say one.
Which item?
Not how many of the item.
I'm gonna bring two, okay?
I don't know if that's allowed.
Okay, two jugs of water.
Yes, two jugs of water!
And then you won't be thirsty?
Yeah.
For a little while?
Cool.
I think I want to bring a book that teaches me the local language, maybe.
That way I can communicate and maybe it could also include some skills, like good life skills.
You know, like maybe how to use my fluff to make clothing.
Those kinds of things, you know?
Jugs of water!
I don't know.
I like to survive and be comfy.
You know, and just enjoy my time.
I like to survive on water.
I don't know.
I think I could survive, too, without some jugs of water.
Well, if you need water, you know where to find me, huh?
BAU BAU!
Water like you, Ruffians.
What would you bring?
A barrel of salt?
Water!
Are you just saying that Fuwawa is very salty?
I have fluff.
I'm gonna make
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you always for all your submissions.
Remember, you're a very important part of FUWAMOCO Morning, so thank you always for waking up so that hopefully we can start your day on the right paw.
And thank you also for
If you have any submissions, please use the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
For our next stream coming up, we have De-den!
It feels like it's been forever, but today we'll be meeting up with Advent to play Palworld tonight!
BAU BAU!
Has it been more than a week?
I feel like it's really been forever.
What did we do last Friday?
It might be grumpy.
A little bit more than grumpy.
They might be reduced to bones, but we'll find out!
And remember, Ruffians!
The collab today is going to be a little bit earlier than usual.
It's going to be at 4pm PT and 9am JST, so make sure you don't show up two hours later than that.
Yeah, I didn't make a mistake.
Nope!
BAU BAU!
Let's take a look at our schedule!
Well, this weekend we have another Rock n' Rawr Party!
Time to rock!
Yeah, and you know, it's Valentine's Day being next weekend.
Well, I think you might be able to guess what songs we'll be singing, right?
Love songs!
BAU BAU!
We'll make you feel all fluffy and fuzzy, so please join us, okay?
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Oh my goodness.
Daikun!
BAU BAU!
Fishmaru!
Nanya!
BAU BAU!
Grill Jones!
Guess who!
BAU BAU!
Corner Weeks!
Kind Novus!
BAU BAU!
Pension!
PAJESIA.
BAU BAU!
LILALULI.
PIOTRE.
BAU BAU!
NANDOE.
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!
BAU!